wooden crosses in a forest Ukrainian
authorities say they Mark a mass grave
with as many as 440 people dead
authorities made the discovery in the
northeastern city of the zoom forensic
investigators say they will examine
everybody to determine the circumstances
of the deaths It is believed most were
civilians including women and children
in an address on Thursday night
President Vladimir zielinski said more
information would be available on Friday
but accused Russia
there will be Ukrainian and
international journalists in Islam we
want the world to know what is really
happening and what the Russian
occupation has led to butcher Mario Paul
and now unfortunately Israel Russia
leaves death everywhere it must be held
accountable for it the world must bring
Russia to real responsibility for this
war we will do everything for this
isium is one of dozens of towns and
Villages occupied by Russian forces for
months but recently retaken by Ukrainian
troops in their counter-offensive in the
harki region Moscow has not commented on
the graves Ukraine and its allies accuse
Russia of war crimes Moscow has
previously denied it targets civilians
but the discovery of the alleged Mass
Graves hearkens back to bucha in late
March after Russian forces were repelled
from the town the bodies of 458
civilians were found
and in mariupo an estimated 21
000 people were killed during a
weeks-long Siege of the city that's
still being held by Russian forces
now attention turns to isium where it
could be another reminder that it's
often civilians who are paying the
highest price in this war
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Keith